now here is another great holiday
activity arya is lighting up the holiday
season with its
winter wonderland lobby display i
visited aria this week for a sneak peek
[Music]
i feel like i need to go get a christmas
sweater because the lobby here inside
the aria hotel has been transformed into
a winter wonderland
and the centerpiece is this gigantic
sugar palace behind me
it is beautiful and the man behind it is
chef matthew
so how long does it take you guys to
make something like this
we worked on it for the last four weeks
me um the team of course uh
the team is behind us uh they have
flowers and this wall you know a couple
thousand pounds
of sugar for the wall alone you said a
couple thousand pounds this is one ton
of sugar here this wall right here
yeah yeah that is incredible now look at
the attention to detail first off i did
not do that
that was here when i got here i did not
do that but something like this
how long does it take to make this hand
blown is it a flower oh yeah the flowers
are totally probably one day there's
flowers and but this one
maybe a few minutes you know to make one
now the roof the shingles is each one
hand blown
yeah yeah those are poured sugar each
one individually
poured and then sprayed it painted and
you might recognize chef matthew
from netflix's sugar high the champion
his partner andy she's on the other side
we're gonna talk to her right now about
how
you guys make some of this madness chef
andy the attention to details that you
have on your sugar palace are
absolutely incredible let's talk about
the nutcrackers and what you guys did
with the nutcrackers
so here is our display window with our
five nutcrackers
and our pastry team actually designed
the three cakes that the little
nutcrackers are holding
talk to me about too putting the stuff
and
and sticking the stuff in the wall here
of the house how does that process work
so right now we're just gonna add some
finishing touches to around the window
here
um we're gonna torch some snowflakes
just heat it up that's it yep
just a little bit just enough to melt
kind of the surface
and it sticks just like it looks like
you just gotta hold it for a second and
it'll stick and how long will this stay
it'll stay as long as someone like me
doesn't knock it off yes
yes it will shatter all right chef andy
might have the honors as we wrap up to
do the final finishing touches you can
come down to the aria hotel and see this
beautiful
winter wonderland yourself and i can say
that i contributed to this gorgeous
thank you thank you so much merry
christmas thank you merry christmas
the winter wonderland features delicious
holiday treats and drinks and
it's open through january 5th you went
there last year rocky but it was
different though
yeah it was a gingerbread house yes also
edible yeah also edible it's so tempting
it's so i mean you walk in there
and it's so tempting i don't have to
take a bite out of that thing but you
don't want to that's why they sell the
holiday treats which you can eat
and soak in the christmas magic very
cool let's edit to share